every four years the Swiss elect their members of parliament
The House of representatives consists of 200 seats
divided among the 26 cantons in proportion to their population
Canton Zurich
with over 1.5 million residents
has 35 seats. Uri, a Canton with only 37,000 inhabitants has one
issues that are important to small cantons tend to get overruled in parliament
by those topics that are important to larger regions
so the Swiss have found a way to better balance the interests
between the majority and those living in less populated regions
they made a second chamber: the Senate, with 46 seats.
most cantons here have two seats
new legislation or changes to a law need approval by both chambers
after the election of a new parliament
the two chambers come together to elect the government
this is made up of seven cabinet ministers
who represent the main political parties in parliament
the strongest parties in the 2019 elections were the Swiss People's Party
the Social Democrats
the Radical Liberal Party
the Green Party
the Centre Party and the Liberal Green Party
overall the Swiss parliament has remained quite stable in recent years
however the political setup of the cabinet is constantly being discussed